Ladies and gentlemen,
today is an interesting object lesson in how easy it is to fake social proof,
scam people and projected image of success.
All the while the reality is completely different. You're almost like fan hosts.
You just reality is whatever you want it to be right today.
We're looking at eight. Wanna be Bernie Maydoff, uh,
Mr. Dr. Terrence cash. Now, first of all, what a name?
How did these people come up with it? Derek money, Berg, Wesley billion,
dollar Virgin Dan, the trillion dollar man Pena and Dr. Terrance cash.
They all go in the Pantheon of great business. Coach wealth, coach,
financial coach names. They're all going to help you and look let's,
let's see what he's doing before we get into how it all fell apart. You know,
all the crazy stuff now going on in the press,
let's get into who this guy was like. Let's say you didn't, you know,
you're looking at him a few months ago. What do you see? The four coffees.
Ella makes a video about a before.
All this stuff happens right before it all comes crumbling down.
This is basically what you get on his page. It just projects success, right?
He's uh, he's on a magazine. It looks like right over here. And um,
you know, it's like transforming your wealth and he's a wealth coach,
but his name is Dr. All that kind of sounds credible. Right?
He's got a little video for us. Let's see that everyday people struggle,
but they have no plan. They don't know the money rules used by the wealthy,
but lucky for you, Dr. Terrence cash is willing to help you out.
Out of the kindness of his heart.
I am not hiking through the Himalayas, went out and guy,
I'm simply not doing it. If you want to do it, send me the pictures.
I guess he's saying you need a coach or something like that. Okay? Whatever.
He's got a wealth creation course, you know, this kind of thing.
And most importantly, something I want to draw your attention to.
He's got the strategic diversified investment chairman's fund. Okay.
Bite you with passive income later on,
he would say that this is 12% a year guaranteed.
It's why he's a wannabe made.
Cause that's what ma Bernie Madoff was famous for offering somewhat reasonable
returns that were just high, like 10% a year. It's not too much,
but it was consistent. Right?
And so that's what made off did it's exactly what this guy did too.
But the big takeaway here is that Dr. Cash, okay.
Had every trapping of success. He was going to events.
He even raised $4 million for his chairman's fund, right?
Where he supposedly taking on investors and paying them out 12%,
everything seems to be going great. In fact,
he's got a whole sob story about how it used to be broke, but now he's rich.
Thanks to, uh, the,
the rich people who shared their secrets with him that he's willing to share
with you. Now.
16 Years later that once failing business was now producing over
$30 million in annual revenues.
You heard it right guys, Dr. Taryn's cash has a $30 million a year business.
Ultimately after considering a nine figure IPO,
he enjoyed private sale of the business for eight figures.
He's super wealthy, all this stuff. You get the idea. So
why do I hear sirens?
It's pretty simple because everything you just heard is all
a fabrication. See all his, you know, chairman's fund all that stuff.
It's all a gigantic fraud. In fact, Dr.
Cash was just arrested for securities fraud from all his investors. So let's,
let's take a peek inside of this complaint letter from the sec and
DOJ, it gets spicy.
Now the first thing to note is that Dr. Cash shockingly is not his real
name. His real name is Terrence chalk,
which I'll admit is a little less inspired than Dr. Terrence cash.
But the reason that he changed his name is very interesting.
You'll be interested to know, see Terrence chop. He's a convicted felon.
You'd never know that by searching Dr. Terrence cash. It doesn't,
it doesn't come up.
That's why he changed his name is so that he wouldn't come up.
That he's a convicted felon. Why is he a convicted felon? Well,
back in the two thousands,
Terrence was arrested for identity theft and conspiring to make false statements
to financial institutions.
Apparently he applied for loans using the identifiers of a dead relative.
This.
Is Dr. Terrence cash for you. Okay.
He also apparently submitted fraudulent documents to a BMW car dealership in
order to secure a BMW vehicles for associates of his,
he was imprisoned for 76 months before getting out and then claiming that he
some successful entrepreneurs, see he calls himself the nation's number one,
business money and wealth coach,
which is kind of Alaris because he just got out of prison for financial fraud.
And he's trying to teach you about money.
Remember that he has whole speeches about how the difference between you and the
rich is your relationship with money.
You see the difference between many of us and the rich,
affluent and wealthy is that the rich have a much more enlightened,
expansive mindset.
Oh yes, guys, he's got an enlightened and expansive mindset of money. See,
once you get your enlightened mindset,
you realize that scamming people is a good way to make money.
Once you get enlightened, like Terrance jock, you realize, Hey,
maybe I'll just forge some docs,
maybe get some cars with dead relatives, change my name,
then create a chairman's fund. Literally,
what's so insane about this is that nearly everything that was publicly
available online never would have suggested that everything he said,
the diametrically opposite thing was true. For example,
he said he sold his business for a ton of money,
but we find in the sec complaint that that is not true.
He was a convicted felon and his previous businesses had suffered financial
difficulties.
And until his arrest chock repeatedly attempted to prop them up through fraud.
He calls himself a doctor, Dr. Cash. But of course that is not true.
He never received a doctoral degree from any accredited institution. Now,
Dr. Cash would deny that he would say he got a doctor philosophy from CIC,
a international university and seminary with a concentration in business
psychology. There's only one problem with that though.
I went to CIC and they don't offer any
degrees in business psychology. They offer a bachelor in theology.
Master's in theology, Dr. Philosophy and theology, nothing about business.
Isn't that interesting? The stuff is completely insane. So, uh, yeah,
he claims to be successful. He's not successful.
He didn't have a successful computer company. It was floundering. Um,
he claims to be a doctor. He's not a doctor. Uh,
he claims to be this retired guy. Instead he went to prison.
He claimed to have this great mindset on money, but apparently yeah, again,
convicted for financial fraud. And then also he claims you're gonna make 12%.
And instead he's not even investing most of that money.
Apparently most of it was used to make a combination of personal and business
expenses,
approximately $1.7 million to pay bills for personal credit cards,
which is just for a guy who's preaching financial literacy.
You're spending a lot of money.
This is the guy who's always citing financial imprudence in all his lectures
citing like how basketball players have a bad mindset with money.
How can you tell it's?
Because they're constantly spending too much money and going broke after making
so much money. That's just evidence that people have a bad mindset of money.
The average NBA basketball player makes about 6.4 million per
year. Over 70% of all NBA basketball players can be broken.
But you're the guy who's spending $1.7 million on a personal credit card.
So moral of the story don't trust anybody
with the name of cash, uh, doctor,
if you can't find where they got their doctorate degree,
don't trust anybody named million dollar billion dollar trillion dollar man.
I mean, it's just, I don't know. This stuff is pretty obvious, but, um,
it's worth two orthopedic guys stay safe out there.
It's the era of COVID that scammers are running muck and luckily some of them
are going to be going down. And when they go down, coffee,
Zillow will be here to celebrate,
to celebrate the conviction of just one more scammer,
sweeping them off the street, one fraudster at a time. Thanks for watching.
And I'll see you guys next time and don't forget.
Smash like and subscribe. Thank you.
[inaudible].